[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation talking about the
issues that matter to you the most
tonight as world leaders gather in Egypt
for the cop 27 climate Summit is the
UK's commitment still as strong
in a world of difficult economic
conditions are we prepared to make the
changes needed for a Greener future and
exactly how much should wealthier
countries historically responsible for
climate change contribute to helping
poorer Nations reach Net Zero I'm Trevor
Phillips and this is the great debate
[Applause]
foreign
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
as we consider the big moral and
economic questions of the climate debate
our viewers panel from across the world
and very much across the country will
tell their stories and have their save
join us in the studio this week are
Jonathan porritt sustainability
campaigner and founder director of forum
for the future
Indigo rumbolo climate activist from
just stop oil
Professor Nick Butler energy Economist
at King's College London
and from the cop 27 climate conference
in charmal Sheikh Carlos nobre the
Brazilian climate scientist
the big question tonight
can we afford to prioritize the climate
[Music]
right now every government in the world
is off course
this news that Boris Johnson is going to
attend absolutely will undermine Rishi
sunx position on climate change we start
the show today with a U-turn by the
Prime Minister breaking news to bring
you in the last few minutes the Prime
Minister has confirmed that he will
attend the cop 27 climate Summit in
Egypt after all
we are on a highway to climate hell with
our foot still on the accelerator I'm
the spirit of Glasgow that's what I'm
doing here I'm the spirit of Glasgow uh
cop 26.
before coming here today I spent last
week working on the difficult decisions
needed to ensure confidence and economic
stability in my own country but I can
tell you today that the United Kingdom
is delivering on our commitment of 11.6
billion pounds
[Music]
let's start as we always do and go to
our viewers panel and when I said we
were
talking to people across the world I
meant it let's talk to fires alarm who
is in Lahore in Pakistan fires thank you
for joining us what's your view
it's an honor to be the part of this the
great debate I believe that I would be
able to tell people what exactly
Pakistan has been through and how
Pakistan has been challenged from the
world I must say that with less than one
person in the global you can say carbon
emission we have paid the huge amount
and in the morning when you get up and
the prime minister of Pakistan comes to
know that the 40 billion dollar has been
lost due to the floods and around 2000
people have been killed it's one of the
you can say the biggest and the saddest
news for the history of the Pakistan I
must say Pakistan has faced around in
2010 2011
2014 2022 we have faced one of the
biggest floods of the history of the
world unfortunately we as a part of this
thing have been you can say
we didn't play it such a big role in
this particular thing but unfortunately
we are paying the price and I strong
only believe that
okay fires thank you so much I think
we'll be almost
thank you so much for painting that
powerful picture let's talk to Natalie
Cristiano who uh is in Cheshire but uh
has background in Brazil I think
oh hello good evening yes so I'm
Brazilian I've been living here in UK
for 13 years now in in Cheshire
and our our country in Brazil is going
to a turmoil as you guys can see on the
news and the part of that is that I
voted for Lula da Silva the current
president is bolsonaro and one of the
things that most is hurt in Brazil and
um it really it really pushes me to say
okay enough is enough I want to change
that is Amazon Amazon is going through
all of these um Liberation in terms of
the highways allowing the all the
devastation uh the indigenous people who
are losing losing their territory and
then it's so sad and for that it is I
I'm so happy to know that now we're
going to start again and we're going to
have Lola and bolsonaro will we will
stop this deforestation there okay
that's Lee thank you very much of course
half of Brazil did vote for the other
guy but I I think we take take your
point let's go now to Jamie who I think
has a question for our panel Jamie
hello
um given that there are so many pressing
matters at home would it not have been
more practical to send Minister and team
to cop 27 and then upon their return
have them present their findings and
recommendations to the prime minister
thank you very much Jamie that's a very
current uh question so Jamie's question
for our panel will our prime minister's
presence make a difference at cop 27.
Jonathan you've been fighting this
battle for gosh longer than I think you
want me to say on television do you
think Richardson acts presence that
charmel Sheikh will make a difference
I'm not sure whether his presence will
make a difference or not but the
presence of world leaders definitely
makes a difference it is really
important and it's
so easy for people to be cynical and
dismissive about these conferences and
they often don't deliver as much as one
hopes that they might but if they didn't
happen like this every year we'd have to
invent something similar this is the
hardest transition that humankind has
ever had to engineer so not to have
world leaders coming together like this
would be a disaster but I'm wondering
whether uh our lead will make a
difference let's bear in mind uh
president she's not there Prime Minister
Modi is not there President Putin is not
there what difference does algae make
I'm sorry to say I don't think he's
going to make much of a difference in
himself I don't want to start on the
wrong note Trevor but the truth of it is
our prime minister knows very little
about climate change he was pretty much
of a disaster when he was chances of the
exchequer he hasn't had much time to
read up on it I doubt he understands the
science he'll read out some good
speeches that are written for him he
will of course be very in a difficult
place but because of the things that
he's doing back here in the UK okay
Indigo are you glad to see Rishi going
to uh mosheik or not well showing up
it's the bare minimum really I'm 28 this
is cop 27 every single year I've been
alive more and more and more emissions
we're spewing out into the atmosphere so
for me you know one conference once a
year to determine whether Humanity
marches towards Extinction or whether we
attempt to save ourselves it's really
just not enough and that's why myself
and many young people just feel
completely betrayed by these world
leaders and the very small tokenistic
way they treat this immensely enormously
important issue well so we can see that
there's some support from our audience
with that uh big Butler um these are
rather pessimistic proposition isn't it
Indigo says the whole thing doesn't
matter very much Jonathan says our prime
minister doesn't matter very much what
is what there's a point what are we
talking about here well I think he was
right to go Trevor I think world leaders
should gather and discuss this is a very
important issue and things are getting
worse as Jonathan says but I was very
disappointed by what he said uh I think
he should say that this process is
failing that it's not producing results
that emissions continue to rise and that
the search for a mythical Global deal
which has been the theme of cop for 25
years and more it is an illusion and I
think it'd be much better to have
coalitions of the Willing around the
science that is actually going to solve
this okay there's a lot of support for
that I wonder if we can go back to our
audience and talk to
uh some somebody who comes from a
country where
um what a world leader has turned up uh
Mr Schultz has gone from Germany and
Adrian Schmidt uh Breton uh I think has
a view on this Adrian
yes good evening
in Germany I'm actually working for the
international commission for the
protection of the Rhine is the oldest
environmental River Commission in the
world and we are basically really much
in the Rhine Basin in Germany also
um impacted by by climate change so we
we tend to say climate change is not
only knocking at odor but really entered
in the rhinehouse just two examples of
negative impacts we had so far uh last
year we had a extreme heavy rainfall and
floods in Germany and other Rhine
countries which uh impacted the Rhine
very much we had 30 billion euros
damages 220 deaths so it's very dramatic
event and on the other side two years
now four years ago in 2018 but also this
year very uh big impacts negative
consequences uh coasts from low water on
on shipping on the Industries on the on
German uh Germany economy and just a
figure here 2.5 billion euros were lost
by German Germany Industries and economy
due to this low water giving the fact
that uh that shipping is uh the the
Rhine is the most important shipping
Lane that's a very very
of the impact of this but what we're
also wondering about is the extent to
which what's happening in Sharma Sheikh
will make any difference to the kinds of
things that you've been talking about or
we've heard from uh Lahore
Charter Schultz is going
um
what's that going to what is chancellor
Schultz's going to charm on Sheikh going
to do to deal with the problem that
you've talked about in a rhyme why is
that going to make a difference
that's it's a very good question I could
return it to you no no but um I think
that's um I have to say we are more
working already on mitigation on
mitigating the impacts of climate change
we we know that diamond change cannot be
stopped so quick so this is quite
pessimistic the message that we I'm
giving to you today so we are more
trying to to to adapt to to possible
changes to negative changes so uh I
don't know what Schulz will say
but let's say let's prepare for for for
bad or for negative impacts that's maybe
my my message all right Adrian I'm not
sure I've quite got an answer but let's
let's see what our viewers panel thinks
about this you've heard reviews about
cop 27 and of course our prime minister
let's see what the sentiment is here
specifically on whether you think our
prime minister
is going to make a difference to what
comes out at cop 27 those are things
that Rishi can make a difference hands
up please
well
it seems that you have all been seized
by an absolute
no-ness tonight nobody much thinks that
Richie is going to make a difference
Jonathan yeah which is a bit depressing
isn't it um you see I'm not quite with
Indigo on this one because I I can see
the frustration for anybody who's trying
to make change happen as fast as it
needs to happen but if you don't get
these people together to confront some
of these things that testimony from
Pakistan for instance
this is a cup taking place in Africa all
those African countries are going to be
in the faces of all of those Western
leaders saying you do not know what this
feels like on the ground in Africa and
that's really important India
um it's not that they're not making it
better they're actively making it worse
like if Rishi was there and he did
pledge no new oil and gas that that
really would make a difference that
would send
um
an alarm to the whole world let's come
off fossil fuels I believe it was in
Glasgow the first time they mentioned
all right let's
um Aisha who is uh
who is from Pakistan has been listening
to this um Aisha you're hearing this
debate about whether it makes a
difference or not you're right there
what's your feeling
okay she can't hear us but I would like
um so yes I'm talking to you from
okay I'll come back Nick what what do
you think about this this argument here
that about whether it actually makes a
difference that they're all there or not
I think it would be symbolically bad if
Richie were not there and the UK was not
properly represented but I think the
agenda is you've had people on from
three or four different countries
and what is being discussed there will
not make any positive difference
unfortunately to any of them and I think
that we need to take apart the process
change it and do something that has a
real immediate impact all right we're
going to talk about immediate impact in
a moment you're watching the great
debate stay with us up next is blocking
the roads and throwing soup at Priceless
art work necessarily the thing to do to
make a point about the urgency of the
climate crisis
three times
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Parsons and Sky's Europe correspondent
based here in Brussels
a volley of rocks troubles have been
pulled up out and are being used as
missiles for help at these police
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
foreign
to be the best and most trusted place
for news
we have now left Italy and entered
France nobody's asked to check our
identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again Mr Barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
Glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's a devastating actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing cop 27 and asking can
we afford to prioritize the climate
part of the M25 has been closed again
today after a climate activist climbed
onto an overhead Gantry causing
tailbacks for Miles as traffic ground to
a halt just stop oil has been calling on
the government to abandon plans to
license more than 100 new oil and gas
projects by 2025 the police say that
more than 10 000 officer shifts have
been dedicated to policing their
protests since the start of October
so how do we feel about the ongoing
climate protests
let's talk to Owen Williams uh Owen I
think you are in wrexham and you've got
a question for our panel
sure
um well I'm heartbroken and embarrassed
that protesters like Extinction
rebellion and just up oil given climate
change such a bad name they're turning
otherwise reasonable people completely
off by making an enemy of them
and they're giving climate deny is an
easy target
they're saying you know these are the
kind of people who believe in climate
change the ones who are blocking your
roads and closing your Bridges don't be
like these people
so my question is
do protesters give climacools a bad name
thank you very much Owen stay there
um
Owens question for our panel
does panel action does direct action
give the climate debate a bad name
indigo
well it's clear to see that this these
forms of action do work so after the
extinction Rebellion protests in 2019
that was the first time that climate
ranked in the top three concerns for the
British population
um insulate Britain they were in 2021
and after their protests we saw searches
for the term insulation double
and now just stop oil is causing this
disruptive action we're sorry for all
the disruption that has been caused but
it's clear that we're exposing this
government for what it truly is and
that's a government that would prefer to
lock up young people than it would to
promise them a livable future well
you're not really sorry though are you I
mean you think it's a good thing
I think it's really important that you
and I'm sure many of your viewers at
home understand the the seriousness of
this situation and that we come together
there's kind of a United agreement
amongst the panel that this cop process
isn't working politics has failed us oil
companies have failed us so what left do
we have to do but take to the streets
and demand that the government just stop
oil
Jonathan um
where are you on this uh this is your
lifetime's work
yeah
um I'm full of admiration for what just
stop oil is doing I absolutely get
Owen's point that he raised about the
degree to which this is interpreted by
some as a really bad reflection of what
the climate movement as a whole is all
about
but I'm completely with Indigo on this
we've tried everything for 40 years to
get people to change their ways so when
I listen to the words of those
campaigners
today and on many previous occasions and
I listened to their integrity and their
courage and I think about the Craven
hypocrisy
and cowardice of our politicians I know
where I stand on this and people who are
a bit unhappy about what it says about
the climate movement you need to
understand we are not getting to the
place we need to get unless we have a
lot more direct action but I wonder if
you really believe that
stopping uh elderly couples going about
their business and interfering with
ambulances creating tailbacks 10 miles
long is making most people more
sympathetic to the cause that you
prosecute
do you really believe that I'm not sure
it is making most people more
sympathetic I think it's making an awful
lot of people listen
to voices of the young with a lot more
attention
Nick and I with great respect we're far
too old to think that this our future is
not sorry
there's no age
show and frankly uh but truly Nick Nick
you you were at uh you worked for an
energy company big Energy company for a
long time did this kind of action
actually change
what BP did no and I agree completely
with Owen and his question I think it's
uh really detrimental to the serious
argument on climate change
to have protests that turn people away
from uh positive views of what could be
done and I think the protesters who I I
don't doubt their integrity or their
honesty of court of their cause but I
think they should really think about
what they're doing the impact this
course is going to be one if it's one at
all through public opinion and to turn
that away I think the protesters should
be turning their skills and their energy
to coming up with Solutions rather than
just blocking normal people going about
their lives well you can't say it
immediately but uh this question is
rather divided our audience who are
enthusiastically clapping both ways
um unfortunately I can't go to uh Carlos
nobre because we've lost the link but I
do want to talk to sue conliff who
herself has gone on a bit of a journey
on this one I think so what's uh what's
your view
well I think until recently I thought
that climate activists were at risk of
losing public Sympathy by vandalizing
artwork
but then I heard one of them speak and I
actually got their message
um you know what they're saying is why
is society more angry at people who are
damaging a piece of art than we are
about companies irreversibly Wrecking
our most precious commodity
our world
you know you hear these activists and
they are really scared in fact some are
too scared to have children why are we
arresting our modern day let's call them
our climate suffragettes when the CEOs
of polluting companies not only get let
off prosecution
but they're having their pockets lined
with huge profits
okay
Indigo explained to to me the chain of
process but goes from throwing soup at a
well-loved Priceless piece of art
to changing policy that brings Net Zero
closer how does that work
yeah and we're talking here about
winning over hearts and Minds bringing
people along
um but we already have a majority of
people who want to see tougher action on
climate over two-thirds of them
do all that stuff aren't acting because
companies like BP have shrouded the
whole debate in total misinformation so
we have to disrupt the everyday life
that everyone's living and say look
we're in a completely catastrophic
situation we need to come together and
act on this and that's what we're doing
we're calling people into resistance
with us let's talk to
um someone in the Isle of Man Chris
Roberts
um who's I think has called in from our
first panel Chris what's your view on
this
um well yeah prostate protest is fine
we're living in democracy however you
know climate protesters I feel need to
grow up a little bit and speak you know
talk about you know the the issues
rather than ruining people's lives
people trying to get to hospital
appointments people trying to get to the
doctor etc etc the general public are
aware of climate change and I believe a
lot of people take it very seriously I
know we do in the Isle of Man and my
wife and I do we don't need people
gluing themselves to the um to the
highway all the time and as I said
getting in the way of people's General
lives you know their attention Seekers
that's all I'm going to go back to
Indigo on this but Chris before we go to
Indigo you and I are of not that
dissimilar vintage and I think we can go
both remember a time when people thought
this was a slightly wacky on the edge
marginal cause the the then Prince of
Wales was a bit strained to talking to
his plant and so on surely this kind of
protest has put it into the public
domain in a new way
no I don't agree I don't agree
um this Summer's Dr hot weather in
England fires in the USA floods it in
Bangladesh that's putting it in in the
people's minds and the people's
eyesights you know that people aren't
stupid
um the yeah we should have been
listening to this 30 years ago I was a
lot of people weren't but now it's
inescapable
you we see it every day the the the
climate in the island of man thank you
uh Indigo I suppose the point that Chris
is making here is not to disagree with
the argument that you're making and in a
sense what he's saying is we don't need
to disrupt people's lives to get people
to agree with your argument that this is
actually just theatrical performance
rather than actually changing anybody's
mind
so the the disruption will end when the
government makes a statement that it
will end new oil and gas
that's an ultimatum is it
it's an extremely strong point there is
a real Focus here the hypocrisy of a
government saying it cares about climate
change and offering up a hundred new
licenses to oil companies that are
making massive profits in the North Sea
and building okay a new Coal Mine the
hypocrisy is beyond belief of Trevor all
right how much longer is this going to
go on
well it won't go on any longer for this
part but you're watching the great
debate still to come we speak to the
mayor of Copeland in Cumbria about why
he wants a coal mine to be built in his
area as soon as possible
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing cop 27 and asking can
we afford to prioritize the climate
environmental campaigners are urging the
government to reject plans for the UK's
first new deep coal mine since the 1980s
a decision on the project near
Whitehaven and Cumbria has been delayed
until after cop 27. supporters of the
Mind have criticized what they see as
the latest delay to a project that
promises hundreds of jobs for the area
a little earlier I spoke to Mike Starkey
the mayor of Copeland who argues that
the mine will bring a much needed boost
the case is economic you know it's going
to bring 2 000 jobs to our community uh
much needed jobs it's 160 million pounds
worth of private investment you know
that's not government funding or
government intervention it's a private
Capital coming in and it fits perfectly
with it perfectly with the government's
leveling up agenda but I think we should
be clear you know a lot of the confusion
um it's cooking call we're looking to
mine here in Whitehaven and not thermal
call to burn for an energy but caulking
call for the production of Steel and if
we're going to have a green Industrial
Revolution we with wind wave soul and
you know hopefully for our area nuclear
we're going to need substantial amounts
of Steel and it cannot be manufactured
viably without cooking call so it's
crazy to be importing corking core from
around the world when we've got high
quality cooking core beneath the ground
here in Whitehaven we get the point that
this isn't going into people's
fireplaces but nonetheless it is
basically
an increase in the use of thermal energy
which at this time given cop uh the cop
uh event in Egypt seems really at odds
with where the world wants to go
it's not at odds uh you know as I've
said this caulking call that's
exclusively for the manufacture of Steel
and there's a huge demand for it a
worldwide demand and you know even in
this country this year
by 44 over the same quarter as last year
indeed but it's it but it's still
increasing industrial emissions you
can't make steel put even high quality
steel without increased emissions you
you can but you know what we're doing
here is we're
you know we're not going to be shipping
coal around the world you know we're
importing call at the moment from the
United States and from Australia and as
the carbon footprint of shipping it
around the world it's not mined in
anywhere near as modern a facility as
we'll have here in Whitehaven this is
going to be the most environmentally
friendly mine that's ever been
constructed so the extraction process
um is going to be more environmentally
friendly than where we're getting the
call from currently but the point is if
you if you were the Prime Minister and
you had been in Egypt today and you had
met the Indian delegation or the Chinese
delegation
how would you respond when they say to
you
you're telling us to reduce our
emissions our dependence on fossil fuels
particularly and including coal when you
are adding to those emissions by opening
a new mine in Cumbria and it may be
small but the point is you're opening it
in order to benefit your people but what
you're saying is we mustn't use fossil
fuels to benefit our people
I think what uh you know certainly well
I'd be saying and what I think what the
Prime Minister can quite proudly say and
what he can quite proudly point to is
the United Kingdom's record in reducing
emissions you know in terms of the call
for energy
um we'll have eradicated that by the end
of 2024 and I think you know Richie
sooner could quite easily stand upon the
stage and he could say to all the
leading nations in the world if you
could get to the stage sometime in the
near future where the United Kingdom
have already got to will have made a
giant leap forward in the fight against
climate change Mike I know that the
decision hasn't been made but right now
tonight if you had to assess the
likelihood it being granted permission
being granted on a percentage basis what
is it 50 50 better or better
well you know I would hope you know
we've got processes in this country
we've got a planning process and this
mind's been approved by the planning
panel on three separate occasions you
know it's now gone to a planning
inspector and I'm a certain a certain
can be that the planning inspector will
have recommended approval because if he
hadn't
um we truly have heard about that now
that wouldn't have strung the company on
or the investors for this length of time
so I'm okay 100 confident as I've always
been that this mind will go ahead
because it's exactly the right thing to
do it's what the United Kingdom needs
okay it's certainly what West Columbia
needs and what the people of West
Columbia needs and it fits perfectly
with the government's level and upper
gender and as I've already said you know
the the the climate objections uh yeah
are minuscule by comparison
okay let's swiftly go to our views panel
and talk to Kevin Cruz Kevin you have a
point on this
oh hi there hi hi Kevin hi um Trevor yes
I have um
he's serious about climate change
um how can this be if he agrees to build
coal mines in Cumbria so my question is
to the panel is should there be coal
mile coal miles built in the UK which is
obviously going to increase global
warming okay thank you very much Kevin
says a question for our panel
do we need a new coal mine in the UK
Nick Butler I think on all these
projects that are now on the table in
the UK
including the offshore licenses that
Jonathan was talking about before the
question is is there a viable
alternative
on this point on the coal I believe
there are viable alternatives for
producing steel which don't involve
coking coal I think you see them around
the world I think they work and I think
we should be trying to build up that
industry here I think on the nuclear
proposal for sizewell I think that is a
complete waste of money it's supposed to
be green but I think it is very
disruptive of the environment in Suffolk
and there is an alternative which is
smaller nuclear reactors a small nuclear
and that's a new technology isn't it it
is a new technology but it's doing
pretty well so far Rolls-Royce are
pretty good at doing it and I think that
that would be a much better and cheaper
and quicker alternative and bringing low
carbon electricity on stream quicker
than size will and then on the offshore
licenses finally I think that they are
needed and I think that if we don't have
them because we still use a lot of oil
in this country and we import it we will
be importing that oil from Saudi Arabia
or Venezuela or some other rather
unpleasant country so I think we should
go ahead with those don't support it I
mean we can all agree about where we
want to get to more Renewables perhaps
more nuclear and so on and so forth
but the case has not yet been made has
it that we don't need some fossil fuels
to uh get through what people call the
transition to this happy State and that
it's a sort of fantasy that we can just
turn on the windmills and change
everything tomorrow
there's a somewhat pejorative slant to
your question there Trevor as you know
um these windmills as you call them are
probably the most astonishing new
technology that the world has ever seen
in terms of offshore technology offshore
wind power which will bring more energy
solutions to more people than any of the
Technologies we've been talking about so
far so this is not this is about time
this is not fantasy we have to get out
of fossil fuels as fast as we can so we
need the minimum amount of fossil fuels
to help us through the transition and we
certainly don't need new fossil fuels
that are not called for totally agree
with Nick we need to be focusing now on
different ways of producing steel
particularly using green hydrogen and
whilst I feel really strongly for the
people of West Cumbria it's a part of
the of the U of the UK I know well I
feel really strong because there are so
many better ways of creating those jobs
okay well we've heard but both you and
Nick actually in various ways have said
we might not need to do some of this
there's another
um area which is of course North Sea oil
which has been run down but there's an
issue about new licenses in the North
Sea uh Andrew Huff uh you're an airshire
and I think you've got um a view about
that
yes and I feel that basically that we
shouldn't be issuing new licenses at the
present time
because they've they've used actually
the down sorry the base load
theory of closing down smaller units
that are not profitable everything seems
to be about profit and for not about
saving the world
Andrew thank you uh I wish we could
carry on with this discussion but we
have to go to the break now you're
watching the great debate stay with us
coming up
as one of the first industrialized
nations should Britain be paying the
developing world to deal with climate
change the climate change we helped to
cause
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
themselves in the islands in the
mainland have the Exquisite Greek food
they they Dash with the music they eat
the sweets they
by the beach up on the mountains during
the summer time but off season also they
started coming early now J2 is a jet
we're going to keep on flying for
November and then March and April so a
Greek Greek weekend
but like that let's see what you did
there yes not just our students here and
how we love Christmas in London and how
we keep on coming back but the bridge I
think have decided they want to talk
about vacations they talk about Greece
128 inhabited islands and the mainland
also I think that people travel as
tourists and of course
you keep on uh uh adventuring in in
Greece and uh keep on finding out new
destinations that's the magic of it it
doesn't stop it's a unique experience
it's a state of mind because since the
ancient days until today
we love to host people strangers
foreigners feed them give them time to
drink give them a bed to sleep and then
off they go it's it's a part of our
culture and of our DNA our airline
companies and carriers thinking about a
low carbo emission yes we go on that
plane do Resorts and and hotels take
care of the environment and recycle the
the garbage for example yes we got the
resort our cities and beaches clean yes
we expect that country or city and we
visit there so our program is a program
of infrastructures public
infrastructures which we will spend
money on to be able to upgrade them in
that extent so how we deal with our
waste how we deal with the water how we
deal with a better location for the
cruising industry in our Islands how we
deal with private Investments as I said
you know to be able to sustain uh and
it's not it's not going to be easy it's
a transition that you need to push
forward and it's one step at a time but
that's our goal in terms of
communication but in terms of
infrastructure also and I think that
will be a Pioneers since we are one of
the top Twisted branches in the in the
world we're seeking to show the way to
everybody else it's not easy to
transform an island into a sustainable
destination but we did it yes has to
Pilot is a small island is a small
island but it's already there so we've
proven to the world that's doable
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing cop 27 asking can we
afford to prioritize the climate
now we're sure to hear a lot about money
at this climate Summit specifically
getting wealthy Nations to make good on
their financial promises to help the
developing world
Scotland's first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon has pledged additional funding
towards irreparable loss and damage for
climate change which industrialized
Nation like the UK have helped to cause
but can the taxpayer in the developed
World expect to be on the hook forever
let's um
talk to Sam
Allah oh no we're going to go to Judith
Randall
in Market raisin Judith
Britain invented the Industrial
Revolution and we
spread it across the world and along
with that
we caused climate change
and that climate change is now is it
it's taken us into a completely
different climate one in which there's a
risk of abrupt accelerating
climate change and we really need to act
now but to me it looks as if we're not
doing enough to support
Africa and other countries that are
developing I think that they're having
to
experience severe drought
famine
and it's it's causing unrest for people
I mean and and also Extinction of
animals and that does that bring you to
your your question for our panel Judith
yeah what should what should we be doing
with regard to Africa
and the developed well I you know should
we be
expecting them to
find the solutions or what
okay thank you Judith well look the
Judas basic questions is why should
developing countries be asked to help to
provide
climate Solutions
Jonathan
where do you stand on this because we
can all agree where we want to get to
but who's going to be responsible
I think this is a question of of Justice
there's no doubting that we were one of
the Nations that contributed most to the
problem today and there's no doubting
there are many countries who contributed
practically nothing who are on the
receiving end and you heard from the
first contributor from Pakistan
um last year the prime minister of Kenya
revealed that six percent of their GDP
six percent of GDP imagine what that
would feel like here in the UK it was
already dedicated to coping with climate
disasters so we have to acknowledge that
we are parties to the damage that is
being done in these countries and we
have to find effective ways of helping
them through that so so directly what
you're saying is
if we have to have tax rises in order to
help Kenya for example or the Maldives
or Mauritius to cope with climate change
then that's something we just gotta
swallow we have to find a way of
effectively financing this I'm not
jumping immediately to taxes because
there are other ways in which a lot of
this climate Finance can be provided but
if we don't start from a principal
position of Justice we're probably not
going to get to the right end point all
right indigo
I I saw a trade Union Leader Gary Smith
of the
General Municipal boilers makers Union
talking on television a couple days ago
and he says that this point of view that
says we need to do all these kind of
things what Jonathan's been talking
about is Bourgeois environmentalism
we're not being realistic and that
actually the people in the
rest of the world are calling us out
um so your question here is can we can
we afford this it's like for for me we
just can't afford not to do it I think
if you hear about the devastating
impacts that happening you know in
Pakistan people being forced to to leave
their homes knee-deep in water imagine
that here in the UK
um okay but the point is we then have to
pay and you're you're happy to make the
argument yeah you're happy to make the
argument that we should pay more because
some poor people here have to pay more
money
um well if you talk about here the cost
of living crisis that's happening here
and yeah okay we want to see um it's
this the root of the problem is the same
thing isn't it it's the government and
the fossil fuel companies dick Butler
I think we should pay something and I
think we are paying something and I'd be
sorry if that was taken out of the
normal overseas aid budget by the
government so I think this is additional
I think we should pay but I don't think
that's the main contribution we can make
I think the real challenge for
developing countries is to move away
from coal
and that I think we should be putting
our scientific skills our research
funding into finding low-cost low-carbon
Alternatives that can change the
environmental situation in the
developing world because if we don't do
that we'll have a clean Britain in a
dirty world and that achieves nothing do
you know that Jonathan that this is the
way to to make our contribution not
essentially to get just hand over money
but to do the kind of advanced research
that Nick's talking about I have no
problem with that and I think the more
we go into targeted and sometimes
bilateral deals with countries that are
really Keen to transition out of coal
they're dependency nobody benefits from
staying in Coal longer than they
absolutely have to a deal was done in
Glasgow last year with South Africa a
specific bilateral arrangement with
South Africa to accelerate its exit from
coal and if we can do more of that then
that is a very important contribution to
that climate Finance story just five
seconds uh Indica do you feel more
optimistic from this discussion yes or
no
I I I I'm not optimistic about the
situation at all okay
all right that is all we have time for
this evening it just remains for me to
say thank you to our panelists here in
the studio
Jonathan porritt
indigo rumbolo
and Nick Butler
of course as always it's your home who
are at the center of our conversation
and if you'd like to be part of the
program next time get in touch email the
great debate at Sky dot UK and for now I
want to thank our viewers panel for
their contributions great questions as
always and great contributions
I know you're at home keep talking
we'll see you again at the same time
next week we'll have another new big
subject for you on the great debate
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign